as the county of the votes continues so
too
are the protests let me make this clear
we're not trying to break in we just
like to watch you count the balance
here in las vegas as well as across the
country demonstrations have been ongoing
since last night supporters of former
vice president joe biden marched in d.c
new york city seattle and portland in an
effort to send a defend
democracy message republicans meantime
asking for vote counting to continue in
states where president trump is behind
while simultaneously demanding vote
counting stopped in states where
he is ahead most of their protests are
taking place at vote processing
centers the police commissioner in new
york says the department there
fully expects protests to continue for
the days to come
we have a couple priorities here we
think that we can accomplish all of them
here
in new york city number one we want to
respect people's right to protest we
continue to see protests throughout new
york city
and we expect that to continue for the
foreseeable future and
we will continue to try to maintain
contact with those
that are holding protests and respect
their right to hold those protests and
work as closely with them as we have in
the past he adds the priorities to make
sure that people protesting are safe
as well as the community at large
election officials across the country
have repeatedly said vote counting is
continuing as expected despite these
disruptions
eight news now is your local election
headquarters stay with us for the latest
results you can find them anytime online
eightnewsnow.com